[Musique]
à l'épicerie fine conserva on utilise
les mêmes méthodes de conservation que
nos grands-parents nous en fournit des
produits du québec est on est on
conserve une idée d'avoir quelque chose
qui était un saison dans l'hiver
toujours frais de bourbon les chefs
massimo vince li et john barreau nous
explique trois façons de mettre en pot
nos légumes d'été de choses qu'on
cherche comment serons un peu en dessous
de 4.65 les ratios qu'on utilise pour le
vidéo avec n'importe quelle carte et
oignons rouges des cornichons des
betteraves
c'est la même technique pour tôt pour
toutes les techniques de mise en
conserve
on doit s'assurer d'utiliser des
instruments et des contenants propres
ainsi que des couvercles honneur
non mais chose enfin c'est vraiment
commencé le liquide l'eau vinaigrée et
au on ajoute du sucre du sel puis on
porte le mélange à ébullition honte
horrifie la coriandre afin d'en extraire
les saveurs lorsque la saumure a atteint
le point d'ébullition
on verse doucement sur le mélange
d'épicés et de légumes crus
as tu besoin de garder un espace de
taille juste environ un petit centimètre
la souris que le bon dieu ici il n'ya
pas parce que ça ça peut affecter le
le coc maintenance a bien assuré que
c'est fermé
on dépose le récipient sur une grille
dans un chaudron d'eau bouillante
pendant environ 15 minutes afin de
terminer la cuisson si respect comme il
faut c'est vraiment juste une fois le
temps écoulé on les place à l'envers
pendant qu'ils refroidissent
nous on fait comme nous 300 mots chaque
fois c'est fini
c'est comme pour une concert dans
l'huile
on débute en préparant les différents
arômes ap auquel on ajoute les légumes
champignons aubergines et poivrons sont
de très bons choix s'en remettre
medellin
je suis anéantie par ses services m la
cuisson 5 10 minutes à l'émission par
l'émission trop trop fort non plus
apprécié en a pas la même principe que
les choux-fleurs volet mettant le
contraire avec une ville sa pointe plus
comme environ 1 semaine pour le bouquet
final
ok en cuisson là aussi ce même principe
fenêtre comme pour les marinades on
plonge les beaucoup dans l'eau
bouillante afin de terminer la cuisson
à
on
d'enfants ici en manquerait un espace
très peu d'oxygène à nairobi d'enfants
avec ça ça me procure des bactéries des
bombes activées la beauté de cette
technique là c'est comme les légumes
sont pas cuits ils concernent tous les
nutriments à côté elle ne te sont
vraiment bons plans santé c'est sûr
c'est pas moi qui ai sont en utilisent
sap a eu quelque chose de super
intéressant quand nous choque route on
peut faire des commissions l'acton
fermenté aussi on coupe les morceaux de
légumes la vie que l'on dépose dans un
pot en laissant et peu d espace pour
permettre à la fermentation de bien
s'effectuer très important du laus
apporte avec lui ça peut donner des
bactéries qui vont
c'est très important avant minimum de 2
% de celles exactement 6
on peut jouer aussi avec deux courses à
jusqu'à 5 tours 5
on verse la solution sur l'ipbx que l'on
peut remplacer par un poivron du chou du
d'alcon et bien d'autres on limite le
dessus la chose importante est vraiment
juste avec un pot masson régulier à
chaque jour comme disait il
dioxyde de carbone qui va commencer sur
le court à toi maintenant il est quand
même très très face à la poussée
demain il va très très vite il faut donc
relâché la pression chaque jour en
desserrant légèrement le couvercle
jusqu'à ce que la fermentation soit
terminé
[Musique]
l'actos fermentation donne un goût et ça
remplace le vinaigre trois techniques de
conservation qui nous permettent de
profiter de l'été tout l'hiver
[Musique]